[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
29 out of 40 which has the highest score
of the night highest score of the night
how did you guys feel hearing that oh it
was so cool
i didn't know when it happened because i
mean obviously i was paying attention
the entire time but i knew mel's score
was really high but i
mean there's so many sixes sevens fives
thrown out tonight that i don't remember
what was what
and so when tyra actually said the
highest score the night i mean i lost it
yeah jenna how did you feel it was great
to see the moment you two first met each
other rehearsal how did you feel being
part of this groundbreaking moment and
dancing with a fellow female for the
first time yeah it was definitely new
territory for me but i
the second i met jojo i just felt like
this was meant to be honestly and the
whole process has been so natural so
smooth
and now i'm like do i even remember how
to dance with a guy like what is that
so like last year like oh my god dad's
gonna die
and you want to talk chemistry you had a
little fall yeah your girl grabbed you
so you know what we're learning this has
clearly never been done before so
note to viewers that want to dance with
another female make sure that your
skirts are shorter than usual because
you'll slip
okay like i did tonight but jojo
held me up like the lead and the
powerful woman that she is i am not elsa
i do not let it go i hold on for dear
life i mean and i feel like you're a
perfectionist so you guys are just going
to get even better from here oh and the
part that was coming up next was our
favorite part too we couldn't miss it
and i was like get up come on even if
even if you're hurt right now we're
still going i loved when you in your
rehearsal package when you said who's
the dude right now me okay cool why what
made you say that well in the beginning
now i know who's the dude and who's not
vegan but in in the beginning there's a
lot to learn you know you're learning
which way you're stepping you're
learning which are your arm is and
really for me obviously the sides are
different using whatever arm is
different but the only dude that the
only difference of dude and girl that i
could figure out is girl goes like this
and dude goes like this
but half the time i didn't know which
one of the trucks to do
well you crushed it
[Applause]
you came with the glitter how much
glitter did we apply tonight this is the
most glitter i've ever worn ever you
have none of it by the way jojo for you
to have out glittered the cast of
dancing with the stars that is saying oh
you have no idea
let me tell the story
jojo took her costume into her trailer
and she has done most of this rhinestone
ink herself she nothing was like out she
did more rhinestones you added on and
then so there's a body makeup artist on
set today
and the body makeup just comes around
and puts glitter on everybody and does
all the things
well she forgot to come to me
or maybe she just did it i mean i don't
know what happened
listen there's a lot going on there's so
many people she had a body glitter i'm
okay
i took a can of hairspray and a tuba
glitter and i sprayed and dumped sprayed
and dumped sprayed and dumped this is a
new technique okay don't try this at
home it's whatever works i said are you
gonna be my girl
who's your girlfriend in the audience
tonight oh yeah how hard was she not
here you know we heard her in the
parking lot we did we wondered
how did that feel and what's her support
been like
kai is literally the best human in the
world i could hear a guy screaming from
the second that i had my first bumper
until my music ended but when my music
started i was like okay just don't
listen to love right now because you
have to hear these four clips like you
have to hit this don't mess it up you
get one try but having cash screen for
me here just made my heart so happy
giving a little i love you i actually
ran outside
and i was waiting for my family to come
by because i was you know gonna do a
little hello to them after i performed
and all i see is just kai sprinting from
the whole other end of the line
sprinting
by the way i love seeing you take a
stand for your music that was very cool
on social media has have you been able
to move forward with that at all i said
i i really want to have an answer by
monday because i'm sure
that i'll talk about it on monday and i
would love to have an answer
i've been here all day there might be an
answer today making my show the best
that it possibly can be is what's
important to me and if i have to sing
the songs from the j team acapella i
will very unhappily do that but i will
happily do that
i think that
you know as an artist i have a vision
and i think that as a human
i also have a brand
and i think that it only makes sense to
have
you know this music in my tour it's a
part of me it's a part of the brand it's
a part of what we're doing right now and
it's honestly beyond me why
anybody would not want this music from
this film to be in the tour but it is
what it is at the end of the day i'm
going to go out there and i'm gonna do
what i love and i'm gonna sing my songs
and behind closed doors whatever goes on
that's what goes on yeah but all i know
is i am so happy right now working with
abc for the last few weeks working with
dancing with the stars all the crew i
have
been on a lot of tv shows and this crew
this cast this network
is amazing the amount of gifts in my
trailer from the network and you closed
the show it's amazing was that cool to
hear you were going to close the show
yeah yeah all right kind of terrifying
but yeah
for the very first
time and jenna
[Music]